[Musique]
et on retrouve Mélanie pocket pour notre
rendez-vous junior bonjour Mélanie vous
allez nous parler d'un jeu de société
c'est ça un jeu de société un jeu
imaginé et conçu pas très loin de 50 ans
en neline Émilie Thomas la créatrice vit
à Bois d'Arcy alors le jeu s'appelle top
chrono c'est un jeu de plateau type jeu
de Loire pour pour se rendre plus compte
les joueurs sont des petites taupes qui
cherchent à manger correctement et
surtout à voler la récolte de dans le
potager de de Monsieur topinambourg et
je vous propose d'écouter la
créatrice l'idée est venue en fait donc
je suis infirmière de profession et je
travaillais en service de de pédiatrie
en service de rééducation et je prenais
en charge des enfants en surcharge
pondérale et l'idée est née à partir de
cette expérience professionnelle où
j'avais noté effectivement une
méconnaissance des enfants concernant le
l'alimentation en général et concernant
les légumes en particulier alors comment
est-ce qu'on y joue Mélanie quelles sont
les règles alors les règles d'abord ça
se joue de de à 6 joueurs vous êtes donc
des petits top je le disais et vous
choisissez trois légumes à voler parmi
tous ce proposer vous lancez le dé et
bien sûr vous avancez du nombre de cases
demandées comme chaque jeu il y a des
petites cases particulières des pon tour
des cases chance et des petites
questions pour progresser d'ailleurs je
voudrais vous faire un petit test
Camille on va en profiter alors première
question à défaut de canne à sutre de
canne à sucre on peut fabriquer du sucre
avec du pot de Chiron de la betterave ou
du navée ça ça va non de la betterave
normalement j'ai j'ai bon c'est ça vous
pourriez avancer d'une case deuxème
question là c'est un peu plus dur lequel
laquelle de ces personnes a réellement
existé le compte d'articha le baron
d'oignon ou la reine d'asperge ouis ça
c'est déjà plus en piège quand même je
dirais le compte d'artichaud ça sonne
bien le compte d'arti c'était le baron
d'oogon alors il s'appelle
US de la Fontaine Solara il était maître
de conférence de cérémonie sous les
règnes d'Henry 2 François 1 Charles et
Henri 2 aussi pardon excusez-moi jeavis
déjà dit petite anecdote c'est à lui
selon l'histoire à qui on devrait
l'expression se mettre en rang d'oignon
alors on revient au jeu c'était la
petite parenthèse celui qui gagne la
partie c'est celui qui a réussi à voler
ces trois légumes choisis au début du
jeu alors faut savoir qu'une partie dure
entre 15 et 20 minutes et Émilie nous
explique cette fois à qui il s'adresse
je l'adresse aux enfants à partir de 5
ans en tout cas pour tout ce qui est de
la reconnaissance des légumes il y a un
système aussi de questions le jeu
comprend 275 cartes questions réponsse
avec des niveaux différents justement
pour permettre de faire jouer les plus
petits avec des questions plus simples
plus basiques alors peut-être une idée
pour occuper nos petits poussins ce
weekend où peut-on trouver ce jeu
Mélanie al il y a plusieurs moyens le
site internet qui va s'afficher en bas
de l'écran là vous allez dans la
catégorie contact et sur le site vous
pouvez aussi retrouver toutes les
adresses des points de vente il y en a
six dans les Evin et un peu partout en
France et il faut savoir que top chrono
il coûte
29,90 merci beaucoup Mélanie poquet pour
cette découverte peut-être un moyen de
faire aimer facilement les légumes aux
enfants aussi on sait Jama en tout cas
on passe maintenant à notre agenda les
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer